- I'm here safely socially
distanced from Joel McHale,
which is how I like it (laughs),
and we're about to get our baking on.
I'd like to think I'm
far enough away this time
to avoid any flour or icing
that may fly in my direction.
- Kelly.
- Right?
- Can they see our butts,
are they just watching our butts?
- No, they see this part!
You just want them to
see your butt (laughing).
- But I feel like they're
just looking at our butts!
- Hopefully this goes better
and less than the last time.
(laughing) You know, you said it
so I looked directly at your butt!
(laughing)
- Yeah, sorry I interrupted.
- And they probably
caught that on camera, it's weird.
Okay, our next guest is a master
at teaching us great cooking skills.
You know her from "Cake by Courtney,"
let's welcome, Courtney Rich everybody!
(clapping)
And it's great to see you again!
- Hi you guys, thanks for having me!
- Oh my gosh, your
kitchen looks so perfect.
Oh, so what are we making today?
- All right, we're gonna make
our own little wedding cake,
or it could be a birthday cake,
but this is a really simple way
to make your own cake
if you've got an event
or maybe it's a wedding
that things have changed a little bit,
but there's no decorating.
It is just like, no
buttercream decorating here,
we're just gonna do a naked cake.
So I know you're both pros 'cause Kelly
we've made cake together a couple times.
Joel, you've made cake before.
- Pro is a strong word.
(Kelly laughs)
- Yep. I'm great.
- [Kelly] Yep, I'm amazing.
(audience laughs)
- I actually, before I ever got on TV,
I was like a prep cook at a bakery.
- Were you really?
- Mhm, mhm.
- Is that a lie?
- Yes!
(all laughing)
- God, you're good!
- Of course he was!
- What's first?
- All right you guys, grab your first
cake layer,
- Okay.
- And we're gonna put
it right on top of our
cake board.
- Got it!
- Done!
- (laughs) Done.
(audience laughs)
- That's it?
- Done! Easy, okay,
- Who do we undress?
- We're doing this, this
is a cookie butter cake.
There's cookie butter cookies in here,
grab your white chocolate.
- [Joel and Kelly] Okay.
- [Courtney] And we're gonna pipe a rim.
- Okay.
- So, oh, just the rim?
- Oh, shoot. (laughs)
- [Courtney] Just the rim.
(Kelly laughs)
You want the creamy white on the outside.
- [Joel] Jeez.
- Okay.
- Beautiful!
- (laughs) I love this.
- Hold on, hold on, hold on,
this is, I gotta do this right.
- Okay, oh, and then
you grab the other one
and you do the...
Oh my God! (laughs)
- Oh no, no, no,
it's gonna go right over to that one.
- He's nailing it.
- Oh, yeah!
- Everyone has their
own special technique.
- That's what this is.
- [Joel] There we go.
- So what's next?
- Okay.
- That's one way to do it Joel.
I feel that's creative, I love it!
Okay but Kelly, if you wanna do it
this way with me--
- She talked to you
like a pre-school teacher!
- Let's take our
cookie butter filling
and put it in the center.
- Okay, in the center center?
- In the center.
- Okay.
- Yep!
- All the way around, okay.
Okay, but--
- Like, I'm almost there.
This is...
- Like, I mean it's so hard!
(audience laughing)
- I did it Kelly.
- I mean it's so...
Is yours difficult?
- Yeah, no, to stay in
place is really hard.
- Get outta there!
Just...
- Okay.
- It's a little cold.
Your set's really cold.
My kitchen is nice and hot right now.
- My set is getting warmer
'cause it's like they--
- [Joel] Kelly what do you think?
- It's coming out and it
looks not good, it's fine.
- I think I got it.
- What are you doing?
Oh my God, yours--
- Kelly, grab your little
bag of buttercream.
- [Kelly] Okay, wait, here we go.
- And use that in the center.
- Okay, so then we do this again,
I'm gonna catch up.
- [Courtney] Oh, I'm gonna keep going.
- There we go!
- Ooh!
- Oopsy!
- Yep,
you're gonna just repeat those steps.
- Oopsy, I'm stressed out.
- Okay, this is going great.
- Oh my God.
(audience laughs)
- When do we get diabetes?
- No one's fast
when they a cake.
I mean, that's in five
minutes right there.
(Kelly laughing)
- Oh my God...
- So, we can do this at home.
If you want to like, clean up your sides,
you can take a little spatula
and just kind of press against the edges
with the spatula.
- Yep!
- When I make a cake and
it's supposed to look
a little rustic, that's
like the best part.
- Mine looks rustic.
- Yeah, mine looks so rustic.
- [Courtney] There's no
right way to do this.
- (laughing) Your top!
- [Courtney] But Kelly, once you have your
last layer on top, we can decorate.
- Okay. I'm done!
- Now this isn't a very big cake,
so we wanna make sure that
we kind of go proportionate.
I don't want to put like
a big pear on top of this
or lots of big things sticking out,
because it's a small cake.
- That would be silly, yeah.
- So I'm gonna do figs.
I love figs right now.
- [Joel] That's a great solution!
- Okay, wait, and you--
- Don't worry too much,
I mean, I can't wait to
see how you decorate it.
- Oh, I think you're
gonna be very excited.
- All right, now what's important too
when you're decorating the top of
one of these small little cakes,
is don't overdo it.
- Right!
- And kind of think of
your cake in thirds.
- Absolutely.
- So, I'm gonna kind of
come to the back side of this cake,
and then gradually kind of fan out.
And I grew up doing art classes
and we were always told to
think of our canvas in thirds.
And so that's how I'll do a lot
of my cakes when I'm decorating.
Get like things in thirds
and do odd numbers too.
- [Joel] Mm! Mhm?
- Joel, your cake is amazing!
(audience laughing)
- Thank you!
- He is talented.
- Kelly, how are you?
- Wait, I'm gonna put,
you haven't put icing on
but I wanna put icing on.
- That's perfect, that is so beautiful!
- Well done.
- Look! I put icing on mine!
- I love it!
- It looks great!
This is one of those things
where the crew is really
excited to try this.
(all laughing)
- Well, and the best part is
this cake is so delicious.
It's cookie butter filling,
the white chocolate buttercream.
- Oh my gosh, yes!
- Oh, you don't have
to tell me.
- So I mean,
if it's time to dig
in, let's eat this too!
- You gotta taste yours.
Go ahead, I dare you.
- Oh yeah, great.
- [Courtney] I've got my fork.
(audience laughing)
- [Joel] There we go.
- Oh shoot.
- I'll just try it like that.
- Oh my gosh, that's really good!
- Great!
(audience laughing)
Yeah!
- It's really good!
- Would you like to try ma'am?
Mm! Go ahead!
- Wait, so Courtney,
while he's feeding the audience,
you launched a podcast right?
What's it about?
- Yeah! You know what?
It kind of brought me full-circle with
my broadcast career that
I left behind to do cakes,
and I'm just sharing a lot
of just hopefully uplifting
and inspiring stories
from everyday people.
So it's every Wednesday,
it launches on all podcasts platforms.
- That's awesome!
- Yeah.
- Well Courtney, thank you so much
for helping us improve our
cake-making skills.
- It's a really good podcast.
It's very dirty, but it's great.
- [Kelly] (laughs) It's great.